- Après quelques changements
de santé
années, j'ai été acceptée
puis j'ai pu faire un don,
puis ça fait du bien.
- Je me suis dit : pourquoi pas?
puis j'ai du sang à donner.
- C'est une bonne journée
à la clinique de sang de la
Place Desjardins : aujourd'hui,
que de places disponibles,
mais c'est loin d'être
toujours le cas.
JOSÉE LARIVÉE, Héma-Québ situatu
Québec, elle est préoccupante.
C'est-à-dire qu'il faut
sans cesse rappeler aux gens
qu'on a des collectes.
- Les banques de sang sont
indispensables et celle d'Héma-
Québec est plus basse qu'elle
surtout pour le sang O positif,s
sanguins, et pour le sang
O négati
- Je suis O négative, alors
donc, c'est un sang qui est
recherché, et, bien en fait,
ça me fait plaisir de le faire.
- Héma-Q- Héma-Q- Héma-Québec an
d'au moins 1000 dons par jour
pour maintenir sa de sang. En c,
on recueille seulement de 80
900 dons par jour et on estime
qu'il faudrait 2000 nouveauxenir
la banque à un seuil acceptable,
à peine 3 % donnent.
Alors il y a de la place
pour des nouveaux donneurs.
- Selon Héma-Québec,
si la réserve actuelle de sang
O négatif diminue encore,
20 % des chirurgies
non urgentes et peut-être plus.
Le problème, c'est
le renouvellement de la banqers.
Il manque de sang neuf
et particulièrement celui
des jeunes, plus difficiles
ROLANDE BRADETTE, on va dans
les universités et les cégeps,
je remarque que les filles
sont beaucoup plus présentes
elles viennent plus souvent
que les garçons.
- Nous, on a essayé de motiver
ils ont pas voulu. Donc
on est venues toutes les trois.
- Je voulais en faire un déjà
dans ma vie, puis je me suis dit
que là, c'était is :
pour les gens qui en ont besoin,
ujours bien.
- Héma-Québec tient annuellement
plus de 1000 collectes de sang
donneurs.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Mon